to figure out whether you know that.
What criterion of knowledge should we apply?
Well, one thing we could do is apply
your own criteria of knowledge.
Maybe your criteria of knowledge is faith.
Let's say it's specifically Christian faith.
Okay, your knowledge claim meets that criterion.
But that was a little easy.
Anyone's knowledge claim is gonna meet their own criterion,
you would normally think.
So that surely can't be sufficient for knowledge.
Here's another possibility.
I'll apply another criterion, an external criterion.
Knowledge is the deliverance of natural science.
Natural science doesn't say anything about God,
says Richard Dawkins.
So therefore you don't know that God exists.
That was also a little easy.
It seemed totally questionable.
So that's the glum of the criteria.
Hegel's idea is that the first horn of the dilemma
isn't actually so easy.
Because in fact, these criteria,
these conceptions of knowledge
that natural consciousness generates
are typically incoherence of their object.
Now, you might ask, so one question you might have is,
well, okay, but I can think of some conception of knowledge
that isn't in the phenomenology of spirit that's coherent.
But that isn't, so to speak,
that isn't sort of argumentatively relevant
to the phenomenology of spirit.
The argument of phenomenology of spirit is if you just
start out with the most primitive thing from itself,
that will develop into knowledge that's so certain
that no skeptical doubt about it can be raised.
Okay, yeah, just one, and then we'll come on.
So, if consciousness alters the standard of knowing,
and then when the standard of knowing changes,
it seems that so does the object that it knows.
So that, how is there ever a one-on-one mapping
of the object and the standard of knowing?
How do they ever meet?
When you change the object of knowing,
you also change the knowledge
that you need to know the object.
And that's exactly what we're about to talk about.
Paragraph 87, page 57.
Okay, so for some reason that I actually don't really know,
the phenomenology is always cited by paragraph numbers.
So, in your papers, please cite it by paragraph number.
And just because I want to drill into your mind,
the fact that we are reading this at secondhand,
you're reading it through translation,
cite the marginal page numbers always,
whenever they're given any of our translations.
Because that's the sort of speak real thing.
The page in Pinkert's translation is just,
the page in what Terry Pinkert is telling you,
they will say.
In this exposition of the course of experience,
there is a moment through which the exposition
seems not to correspond
with what is ordinarily understood by experience.
Okay, let me just back up.
I skipped something.
This dialectical movement,
which consciousness practices in its own self,
this is 86,
insofar as for consciousness,
the new true object arises out of this movement
is properly what is called experience.
So Hegel's technical notion of experience
is not when you took a gap year
and traveled through Southeast Asia,
nor is it the Kantian notion of a synthesis of perceptions,
nor is it whatever Locke and Hume think about experience.
It's precisely that.
It's the dialectical movement
by which consciousness realizes
that its conception of knowledge is incoherent,
that it's not a way of knowing the object
that it takes itself to know
and generates a new conception of knowledge
and thereby generates a new conception
of the object of knowledge.
That's what experience is.
Okay.
Sorry, what?
Can you say it's true or there?
No, sorry.
Okay, in this exposition,
in this exposition of the course of experience,
there is a moment through which the exposition
seems not to correspond
with what is ordinarily understood by experience.
The transition, namely from the first object
and the knowing of it to the other object
about which one says that it is learned from experience
was specified in such a way
that the knowing of the first object
or the being for consciousness of the first in itself
is itself supposed to become the second object.
So Hegel's referring back to some stuff that I skipped,
so I'll just summarize it.
So Hegel's idea is if this is the first,
I'll just erase the thought bubble.
I'll erase the thought bubble
because the thought bubble is now just implied
in everything I said.
Everything that I, everything on the blackboard
until further notice is the name of the thought bubble
because the phenomenology is imminent to consciousness.
We're not talking about objects themselves.
We're talking about consciousness's conception of the object.
What consciousness says is the object of knowledge.
Not what we think the object is or what objects are.
Okay.
So Hegel has said, which he's now referring back to,
is that if this is the first shape of consciousness,
the new shape of consciousness
is that what consciousness knows,
the second object is the relationship
of the consciousness to the object in the first shape.
This relationship is what the object is.
I should actually probably know.
Okay.
Now why isn't it?
So let me give you an example.
Here's an example.
In Kant, the critique of theory is it begins
with what Kant thinks of as the natural presupposition.
I know things in themselves.
And I do throw through sensing.
That is, we're intuiting them.
The argument of the transcendental aesthetic
is that this does not relate you to things in themselves.
You don't know things in themselves.
You know their appearances to you.
So what you know is not this,
but how this relates to you
and how it relates to you in this way.
You know not this,
but how this appears to you in intuition.
So Hegel thinks when you find out that you don't know this,
that this is not a way of knowing this,
the next shape of consciousness is that what you know
is that things relating to you in this way.
So in the Kantian example,
this would be the appearance of things in themselves.
So you start out by claiming to know a certain object.
Your knowing isn't a way of knowing that object.
What it's a way of knowing
is how that object relates to you in that relation.
So that the second object is the relation
of the first object to consciousness in the first form.
Or it's the first relation of consciousness to the object.
By contrast, it ordinarily seems that we learn
from experience of the untruth of our first concept
in another object that we perhaps come across
serendipitously and extrinsically,
that the only thing that is left to us
is the pure grasping of what is in and for itself.
Ordinarily we assume that we think we know stuff
and then we come upon some other objects.
We go explore and we're like oh,
that's not what knowledge was,
but that's a merely empirical case
of undermining knowledge.
We're interested in a sort of categorical collapse
of an entire conception of knowledge,
not some particular things of knowledge.
That's like finding out that Fargo
is not the capital of North Dakota.
This observation of the matter is our addition,
whereby this series of, sorry,
however, based on the point of view given above,
the new object shows itself to have come to be
through a reversal of consciousness itself.
So this new object is, it comes to be
through the undermining of this shape of consciousness.
Then there's a kicker.
This observation of the matter,
namely that the object of the second shape of consciousness
is the first relation to the first object.
It's the appearing of things of themselves,
not things of themselves.
This observation of the matter is our addition,
whereby the series of experiences traversed
by consciousness is elevated into a scientific progression
and which is not there for the consciousness
that we are observing.
So this transition and the fact that the second object
is the first relation to the first object
is not, Hegel says, for consciousness.
It is for us.
What does that mean?
What that means is that if we draw the thought bubble,
this shape of consciousness conceives of itself
as knowing this object in this way,
but the fact that this object
is the first relation to the first object
is not something that it is in self-consciousness.
That is to say, the shape of consciousness
does not know that it arose from this.
It's not constitutive of this shape of consciousness
that it is aware of itself as the successor of this.
Because why would it be?
It's not constitutive to knowing this in this way
that you know that you arose from that.
This is our addition.
So there's a distinction in the phenomenology,
in every scene of the phenomenology,
between what is for us and what is for consciousness.
That is to say, there's a distinction between
what we say about consciousness
and what consciousness says about itself.
And what consciousness says about itself
has to always be imminently developed
from consciousness itself.
So the for us remarks can be preliminary
or they can indicate the shape of the science,
but they can't themselves be,
they can't include the undermining.
Otherwise, the imminence of the exposition would be.
So what we do scientifically is order these things
in this way.
But that, this thing undermines itself
is not something we do to it.
It does it to itself.
But we, what's sometimes referred to
as the phenomenological observer,
the reader and the author of the phenomenology,
we order these shapes of consciousness in this way.
And that generates a scientific development.
So now we have a principled reason
for the beginning, the order, and the end.
And in any Hegelian science,
you always have to ask yourself where it begins,
what the principle of movement of it is,
and where it ends.
Okay, reading a little bit further.
However, this is in fact also the same situation
already discussed above concerning the relation
of the exposition to skepticism.
Namely, that each and every result which emerges
from a non-truthful knowing should not coalesce
into an empty nothing,
but rather must necessarily be grasped
as a nothing of that of which it is the result.
A result which contains the truth
that the previous knowing has within itself.
So this result is not an abstract nothing.
It's not just the giving up on knowledge.
It's this determinant negation of this.
It's, there's something it isn't.
It isn't that.
It's for us specifically not that shape of consciousness
because that shape of consciousness undermined itself.
And this relation is what Hegel calls being the truth of.
So what that means is this,
when it thinks itself fully undermines itself,
and this is what resolves the problem in a principled way.
So this contains whatever was true in this.
Now that means truth is not on or off.
Things are not true or not.
Truth here is a relational notion,
being the truth of something else.
And so things can be more or less true.
This is the truth of that.
The third shape is the truth of the second shape.
As we do this, we get truer and truer.
Now truth for Hegel is gonna turn out to be
the agreement of something with its concept.
So what this is is,
knowledge becoming more and more
in agreement with its concept.
Now what is the concept of knowledge?
We don't know yet.
It's up to consciousness to say.
It's up to the exposition of the phenomenology
to unfold from consciousness what the concept
of knowledge is.
If we just said what the concept of knowledge is
from the beginning, we would be begging the question.
We would be falling into the second form
of the dilemma of the criteria.
Yeah.
Can you explain what it means for something
to contain the truth of something else?
In what sense does the thing on the left
contain the truth of it?
I mean in a certain way, this schematic diagram
is all that can be said about that.
What for something to contain the truth of something else
is for it to be the principled successor to that.
So X is the truth of Y if X is the principled successor
of Y in virtue of Y negating itself.
Yes.
Yes, I have a question.
You've been making a distinction between
what we say about consciousness
and what consciousness says for itself.
But anything we assert as consciousness says for itself,
we're saying it equals something.
Sorry, say that again?
Okay.
So there's the distinction between what we say
about consciousness, namely we order the past consciousness
and what consciousness says for itself.
But how can making this at all means
whatever the wire gets cut by others?
Yeah, okay.
So by consciousness, Hegel doesn't mean
like consciousness in general.
He means by a particular shape of consciousness.
Of course, we're conscious.
But when Hegel refers to something as consciousness,
he means it's consciousness and nothing more.
Not, and this goes back to a point from earlier,
not that it isn't in any way that further thing,
but it hasn't yet grasped itself as that further thing.
So Hegel won't call us consciousness,
although of course we're conscious,
because we are something more.
In particular, insofar as you are reading
the phenomenology of spirit,
you're always one step ahead of a shape of consciousness.
You always know something more than it about itself.
So you are not merely identical
with that shape of consciousness.
So one way of distinguishing this
is thinking about what a shape of consciousness
is implicitly and what it is explicitly.
All of these shapes of consciousness
are implicitly spirit.
They're implicitly absolute no.
Because they contain in themselves the imminent criteria,
which when thought through by themselves
will lead to absolute no.
But they are not explicitly absolute no.
So we are, I'm more than just implicitly consciousness.
I'm explicitly something more than consciousness.
And so Hegel won't refer to me
or himself as mere consciousness.
Yeah.
So choosing the successor of truth,
it's like, for example,
is there a absurd stage of consciousness?
That's the truth of the first stage of consciousness,
also preserved and disturbed in the system.
Yes, yes.
So the truth of is transitive.
So we're going to try to figure that out.
So you guys speak up.
Oh, we're going to be trying to figure that distinction
between consciousness as we felt a number more
and consciousness, what we can claim about it,
could be similar to how we can claim thought and object.
So we are making claims about consciousness
as it appears to us,
just to speak between us making a claim about consciousness
and consciousness as it's also looking more important.
Yes, except that our claims about consciousness
are not supposed to be one of the shapes of consciousness
in this sequence.
Thank you.
Okay, let me just, let me just,
let's just read a little bit further.
However, this is in fact also the same situation
already discussed above concerning the relation
of this exposition to skepticism,
namely that each and every result
which emerges from a non-truthful known
should not coalesce into an empty nothing.
So not just the rejection of knowledge,
but rather must be necessarily grasped
as the nothing of that of which it is the result,
or result which contains the truth
that the previous knowing has within itself.
Here it presents itself as follows.
Well, what at first appeared as the object
generating for consciousness into a knowing of the object,
and in itself becomes a being for consciousness
of the in itself, the latter is the new object,
the being of consciousness for the in itself.
That's this point.
The being of consciousness for the object is the new object.
The previous being of object,
being of the object for consciousness,
that's what this is, is the new object.
As a result, a new shape of consciousness comes on the scene
for which the essence is something different
from what was the essence for the preceding shape.
Okay, so let me just say something about the word essence.
Hegel has this, the word here is vesen.
So now vesen in German is more general
than essence in English.
It can be a being, like an entity can also be a vesen.
So what Hegel means by vesen is whatever the standard
of whatever it is that knowledge has to correspond to
in order to count as knowledge.
So you might think, well, isn't that just
what the object is?
Yes, at the beginning, but over the course
of the phenomenology, something other than the object
is going to come to count as the vesen.
So the progress of the phenomenology is that consciousness,
knowing something that's an object will turn out
to be incoherent.
And then the vesen will turn out to be the subject.
It will turn out to be that what the subject has to do
in order to know objects is come into an agreement
with itself.
But we're not going to actually read those sections
of phenomenology.
So just understand, vesen is like a functional term.
It means whatever is that which knowledge has to correspond
to or agree with in order to be knowledge.
But for now, the object is playing the vesen term.
And in fact, consciousness is more or less identified,
or identical for Hegel, with a conception of knowledge
with the object plays the role of vesen.
Okay, this is what's so great about only teaching
the easy parts of Hegel.
In case you're wondering, this is like the easiest
ten pages of Hegel.
Okay, as a result of, if you guys go,
oh, I don't know how I'm getting through this,
like you have no idea, like it won't get that bad
in this class, but it gets infinitely worse than this.
As a result, a new shape of consciousness comes on the scene,
you can already read that, is this circumstance
which guides the whole series of shapes of consciousness
in their necessity.
So that's super crucial.
The progression of the shapes of consciousness
has to be necessary.
There has to be no arbitrariness or contingency
in one shape of consciousness being the successor
to the previous one.
That's why the merely historical reading
of the phenomenology has to be wrong.
The fact that one shape of consciousness
historically succeeds another,
it does not by itself demonstrate any necessity.
So if all this were, were a super high level
philosophical account of intellectual history,
it would demonstrate nothing about necessity.
What it could be, so there's like the pure historical reading,
this is literally just a catalog of what happens in history
but described in terms of historical period
self conceptions, that can't be right.
What it could be right is it's a description, it's that,
plus each of those historically extant conceptions
of knowledge incoherently undermines itself
and necessitates the next one.
So that's a little bit better, still wrong because A,
Hegel explicitly says that it's false,
the book ends, Hegel says something that's completely
in the battle with that, which we will read.
And furthermore, the chronology is wrong.
In fact, Newtonian science occurred after the ancient Greeks.
So, sorry guys, okay.
There's very few pure historical readers
of the phenomenology of the spirit left
but I have like a bad reaction to this
because I survived my first Hegel class partly
by just ingesting Michael Forster's book
about the phenomenology of the spirit.
The first half of which is very good,
it's all about Hegel's response to skepticism
but the rest of which is just the pure intellectual
distribution of phenomenology, which is very,
which is bad in pernicious.
However, it is just this necessity itself
or the emergence of the new object
which presents itself to consciousness
without consciousness knowing how this happens to it.
So this consciousness is unaware of its own history.
Now at a certain point in the phenomenology,
that will change and a shape of consciousness
will become explicitly self-conscious
of its development out of logically prior
to self-consciousness.
But we're not there yet.
Through this, there enters into the movement
of consciousness a moment of the in itself
or of being for us.
So this is a different use of in itself.
So sometimes Hegel uses in itself to mean this.
Sometimes what Hegel means but in itself
is a contrast between what is in itself and for itself.
And that approximately means what something
implicitly is without grasping it.
And for itself, what explicitly it is
what it grasps itself as such.
So let me give you an example.
Let's use the standard bad movie, The Hero.
Luke Skywalker is the savior of the galaxy
and the savior of the Jedi in himself from the beginning.
But only in Return of the Jedi is he that form himself.
I shy away from Star Wars examples
because I find that they're one of the few pieces
of pop culture that I share, that I know,
that my students also know.
And so then I tend to use them too much.
And then people think that I'm way more into Star Wars.
So then I will try, I will try to use the Star Wars
reference experiment.
Theologically, Jesus is the son of God in himself
before he takes on or accepts that identity.
Then he is the son of God for himself.
It is this circumstance, however it is just this necessity.
So these shapes of consciousness are in themselves
gauges on the path to absolute nothing.
But they are not those for themselves
because consciousness is not aware of that.
And in the phenomenology, the in itself,
but not for itself, can be identified with what is for us
and not for consciousness.
So in the phenomenology we can identify these risks,
what is for us, and what is for consciousness.
Okay.
So just a note on Hegelian tactical terminology.
People, I've had this experience multiple times
that students would be like,
I've been reading the phenomenology on my own
and I totally get it.
Could you just tell me though what the in itself
and the for itself are?
And the reason that question is very hard to answer
and slightly frustrating to be asked
is the meaning of Hegel's tactical terminology,
like everything else, has to be developed
imminently over the course of the science.
So these are to some extent like my external remarks
because I've read this book many times helping you along.
But properly speaking, the meaning of the in itself
or the for itself is going to change
over the course of the phenomenology.
So the only thing that we can say
that's like genuinely true illuminating
is some kind of like general structural features
of how these terms are used.
And in particular, when we get to the logic,
I'll actually, the in itself is actually in the part
of the logic we want to talk about.
The logic develops in principle and purely imminently
the pure technical meaning of these terms.
Which does not present itself for the consciousness
which is itself comprehended in the experience itself.
However, the content of what emerges to us
is for consciousness.
And we comprehend only what is formal in it
or its pure emergence.
For consciousness, what is emerged is only as object.
That is to say, what's emerged is an object
that it claims to know.
For us, what is emerged is that the same time emerges
as movement and coming to be.
But we understand this as having come to be from that.
Well remember, movement is just the name
for this purely conceptual process
of one conception of knowledge undermining itself
and giving rise purely logically to another.
And this process and this movement
is not happening in time.
Okay, through this necessity, this path to science
is itself already science.
Earlier he said, this doesn't appear to be science,
but now he's telling you, this is actually science.
But we don't know what science is.
So that is a provisional remark for something
that will have to be proven by the end of the book.
In fact, in doing the science of logic,
sorry, the phonology of spirit,
we are actually doing science.
This is actually scientific now.
And according to its content, it is thereby the science
of the experience of consciousness.
Okay, now those of you who pay very close attention,
actually this may not have been in the reading,
but if you have a copy of the book,
you'll notice that the title page of this book
is Science of the Experience of Consciousness.
So if you look at this book, it has one title page
that says, Phenomenology of Spirit,
and then it has a preface and an introduction.
And then there's another title page saying,
Science of the Experience of Consciousness.
Why does this book have two titles?
The reason is that the original title of this book
was the Science of the Experience of Consciousness.
Halfway through the book, Hegel decided
that it needed a second half
and that it should bear the title,
Phenomenology of Spirit.
The problem is the first half of the book had been printed.
And in the early 19th century,
paper is very, very valuable.
So the printer was not gonna pulp half of a book.
So instead, they printed the rest of the book
with the original title page
and then just added another title page.
And you can in fact,
that card first has proven this
by examining the very most original first editions
of the Phenomenology of Spirit.
So here at the Thomas Fisher Rare Book Library,
we have one of the very early editions,
but there were even earlier ones.
This is maybe boring, but it's extremely interesting
to me, so I'm gonna bore you with it.
There was a practice.
So book publishers were also booksellers in,
sorry, printers were also booksellers
in the early 19th century.
So a publisher or a printer that was publishing a book,
you could subscribe to that book
and they would send you the parts of the book
as they were getting printed.
So an 18th century book is printed
on these gigantic pieces of paper
that are folded together and then they print off them.
You could subscribe and as those got printed,
they would send them to you.
And then when the whole thing was done,
you would send it back, they would bind it together
and then you'd have your book.
And so Eckhart first found one of these
of the Phenomenology of Spirit
and he proved on the basis of the folds of the page
that the original first fold of the Phenomenology of Spirit
has the title, Science of the Experience of Consciousness
and then when they asked for everybody's folds back,
they cut off a couple of pages
and then added the rest of it.
And he has a claim about these various pages
in Hegel's not lost the papers that were left
over his death about what those missing pages are.
This unfortunately is not something
we're gonna be able to cover in this class.
Now I realize that this may be very sad.
Okay, so why did he go from calling it
a science of the experience of consciousness
to the Phenomenology of Spirit?
Because the original plan of the book
is that it ends, so the book was originally supposed
to contain consciousness, self-consciousness,
and reason.
Spirit is where the, this is the original plan.
This is the original plan.
This is something called the Four Phenomenology.
This is where the second half of the book starts.
So the original plan of the book
didn't have the spirit section.
So then for some reason, Hegel decided
the book needed a second half
that includes spirit, religion, and absolute damage.
Yeah, spirit, religion, and absolute damage.
And he decided that what the whole thing is
is not just the science of the experience of consciousness
but the Phenomenology of Spirit.
So really, this is what was originally
the science of the experience of consciousness.
So now it's possible, and this is the kind of thing
that we would have to deal with
if we were doing a class of the whole Phenomenology,
that this description of the project of the Phenomenology
applies only to this.
And then, imminently, within the reason section,
we transition to a different project.
I don't think that's quite right, but regardless,
what does it mean that the whole thing
is a Phenomenology of Spirit?
Okay, so now this goes back to a question
that was asked earlier.
Who asked this question?
The meeting of Phenomenology.
Yes, Isaac, okay.
So Phenomenology, right, just linguistically,
means the logos of Phenomena.
Oh, this board is really messy, I apologize for that.
But it might just, you know, they do not need to,
they do not need to add weight for this.
Okay, Phenomenology.
This is the logos, or the rational account of Phenomena,
of Appearance.
So this is the science of the Appearance of Spirit.
So it's the scientific account of how Spirit appears
up until, or up and until, Spirit is fully
in and for itself.
It's fully explicit for itself that it's Spirit.
Now, what is the appearance of Spirit?
It's not like Spirit is, it's the appearance
of Spirit to Spirit.
It's the appearance of Spirit to consciousness.
Consciousness is ever more adequate conception
of itself as Spirit.
So this is what I was talking about before.
That means consciousness is ever more truthful,
ever more adequate conception of it not being
fundamentally different from anything else.
Of there not being anything that's radically distinct
from Spirit.
There's no outside to Spirit.
There are things that are distinct from Spirit,
but their fundamental structure is the same
as the structure of Spirit.
And so all of being, all of reality is in principle
transparent to Spirit.
It's in principle transparent to knowing.
Okay, so that means that this introduction
is not an introduction to the Phenomenology of Spirit.
It's an introduction to the science of the Experience
of Consciousness.
That's why there's no explanation of why it's called
a Phenomenology of Spirit.
Although there is an explanation of why it's the science
of the Experience of Consciousness.
And it means that something really important happened
because Hegel decided that the book could not end here.
So once again, in a complete account of the Phenomenology
of Spirit, we would have to,
this transition is really crucial.
Why does the book not end with reason?
Why does it move to Spirit?
And what is the particular nature of Spirit?
Okay, so let's just do the last paragraph.
The experience through which consciousness learns
about itself can, according to its concept,
comprehend within itself nothing less
than the whole system of consciousness.
Okay, so this is an obsession of German philosophy
between Kant and Hegel, the systematicity of science.
So we don't wanna just have science.
Science has to be a system.
However, Hegel hasn't imminently justified
the notion of system.
That he's gonna have to do.
So this is a provisional remark
for something that's gonna come.
And we'll talk about when we get to Hegel's system,
in what way it's systematic.
Nothing less than the whole system of consciousness
or the whole realm of the truth of spirit.
So the moments of truth present themselves
in this, their proper determinateness,
not as being abstract pure moments,
but rather in the way that they are for consciousness
or in the way that consciousness itself comes
on the scene in relation to that.
In this way, the moments of the whole
are shapes of consciousness.
So the moments of the whole are the individual aspects
or parts of this development
from natural consciousness to absolute known.
By consciousness carrying a word
on towards its true existence,
it will reach a point where it sets aside
its semblance of being burdened with what is alien.
So the end point of the phenomenology is willing to be
in part giving up what Hegel here describes
as a semblance, the idea that consciousness is burdened
with an object distinct from itself that it has to know.
Absolute knowing, as I said before,
is gonna involve some kind of getting rid
of the distinctness of the object
or a collapse of the subject and the object together
so that no possible distinction
between subject and object can arise
that would generate the skeptical problems
that undermine previous shapes of consciousness.
A point where the appearance becomes equal to the essence,
the essence being that which has to be known,
the appearance being its relationship to consciousness,
so that its own exposition coincides at this very point
with the genuine science of spirit
so that this exposition will itself also have been,
will turn out to be a scientific knowing of what spirit is.
Finally, while itself grasping this, its own essence,
consciousness will signify the nature
of absolute knowing itself.
So just to anticipate slightly spoiler alert,
this joke that people like to make on Twitter,
the real journey, the real destination
was the friends we made along the way.
This is in a certain way the key idea of Hegel.
Or the slightly less jokey version,
the journey is the destination.
That in a certain way, I'll try to justify this philosophically
over the course of this semester
and make this not sound so silly.
That in a certain way is the key idea of Hegel.
That actually, what absolute knowing is going to be,
is going to turn out to be what we've been doing all along.
So the end of the phenomenology of spirit,
the end of all of Hegel's books
have this weird, dissatisfying character.
You're like, wait, I wanted to know what absolute knowing was.
Why can't you tell me?
And the answer is, you've been owning absolutely all along.
But you've been absolutely knowing in itself.
At the end, you have absolute knowledge for itself.
You absolutely, you explicitly grasp
what you've been doing all along as absolute knowing.
And that is one of the reasons,
if the journey is the destination,
then the content of Hegel's philosophy,
the P in Hegel, is the way you get to the P.
They're inseparable.
Which means Hegel cannot cut to the chase.
That means there's no way for Hegel to communicate
the so-called content of Hegel's thought,
other than by you doing it yourself.
That is why the books are so hard to read.
You have to rethink every of Hegel's ideas
in order to understand every one of the claims.
There's no choice in reading Hegel,
but to recapitulate the thought of Hegel
in grasping the thought of Hegel.
If there was a distinction between form and content,
there could be P, and there could be my argument that P,
and those would be different things.
But for Hegel, they're one and the same.
Which means that they aren't a value of P.
Because P cannot be identical to an argument that P.
I mean, it's a very bad argument that P.
I mean, it's a value, right?
And for many values of P, it is sound as well.
But still, a very valid argument.
So in some sense, where the phenomenology of spirit
is going to end is that this has been absolute knowing
all along.
Sounds super weird, sounds kind of oaky,
sounds slightly new-agey.
But I hope that I will be able to false off and justify it
as not totally stupid over the course of this much.
Okay, we have some time.
I just want to say, those who have taken classes
with me before know that I tend not to keep to the syllabus,
I tend to slow down.
I think in my entire life,
I have never actually kept to a syllabus.
I think one time, I only was like one week behind,
or even like half a week behind.
It's possible that I will slow down from the syllabus.
But there is, I have in my mind,
a kind of condensed version where we can speed
through certain things,
and we'll still start at the beginning and get to the end.
So we'll see the big structure of Hegel's system,
even if we speed through certain things
or slow down on other things.
Questions?
Yes.
So when they say P is the right to get to the P,
so what's the meaning of experience?
Experience is, as Hegel says,
consciousness undermining one's conception of knowledge,
which gives rise to another conception of knowledge.
That's what experience is.
In a certain way, absolute knowing
is not the experience of consciousness,
but the science of the experience of consciousness.
It's that experience in its systematic totalitarian,
a principled beginning, a principled law of the series,
and a principled end.
Yeah.
So is consciousness here a proper noun,
like as you're referring to an entity,
or is it just a functional world,
like in point to that you're conscious of something
that's like a function, not like an entity by itself?
I mean, my inclination is to respond to you
by saying that that's a false dichotomy,
because functions are entities,
and consciousness is definitely a noun, just grammatically.
But I feel like there's something
that's more behind your question.
So what lies behind this question?
So what lies behind the question is that if consciousness
is just a functional world and just a status that I just,
that something is always cognizing,
or like conscious of something,
and that process is like constantly rebooting itself,
and it's not aware that it's even clear of itself,
so it's always for itself.
If consciousness is a proper noun,
as like you're referring to an entity,
then it can sort of like have passed and recognize
the always immediately present in the world.
Okay, so what I would say is,
we're talking about consciousness,
we're not talking about particular conscious subject.
Why are we doing that?
Because we're not interested in this conscious subject
or that conscious subject,
we're interested in what consciousness is.
Okay, now, so we're at one level
above individual conscious subject.
Furthermore, consciousness is relational.
Consciousness is consciousness of something else.
In fact, even consciousness will turn into self-consciousness,
which does not mean that consciousness is not self-conscious
in the ordinary sense from the beginning,
because as you see, consciousness has a conception
of itself as consciousness.
That is to say, in the ordinary sense, it's self-conscious.
So we're not gonna read in this class
the transition from consciousness to self-consciousness.
But there's this thing that people,
there's this reading that you sometimes hear
where somehow, human beings were not conscious
until they started fighting each other
and then they became self-conscious,
which is always very strict,
because animals manage to fight each other.
You look at them without being self,
put two babies together, they won't fight each other,
like wrestle with each other,
but that's not turned them into self,
makes them self-conscious.
Of self-consciousness as the second part
of the phenomenal energy of spirit
does not refer to self-consciousness
in the ordinary sense,
but the idea that what consciousness is of,
what knowledge is of,
the essence that makes knowledge knowledge
is consciousness is knowledge of itself.
So that consciousness,
it sort of speaks self-conscious knowledge of objects.
What it needs to know,
what it needs to match its representation to
is the object.
Self-consciousness is self-conscious knowledge of itself.
What it needs to match its representation to is itself,
including its representations of objects.
So consciousness for Hegel,
even self-consciousness is always relational,
even if it's a relation to itself.
So in that sense, maybe that's what you mean by functional.
Consciousness is not, so to speak, an intrinsic property.
Does your ever-subscribing impact on Hegel's ideal
implicit and explicit?
Yes.
Hegel says at the beginning of the philosophy of spirit
that the only thing worth reading about mind,
aside from, of course, him, is Aristotle's Diana.
Maybe not the only thing,
the best thing ever given by the mind is Diana.
So Hegel thinks of himself,
Hegel's attitude towards true philosophy,
which we will get to at the end of the course,
is that the history of philosophy is,
all of these things that we're gonna describe in Hegel,
so there is a, one of the many distorted ways
in which Hegel has been received
is to think of Hegel as fundamentally
a philosopher of history.
Hegel is a philosopher of history.
Maybe, probably the best,
deepest philosopher of history ever.
But the stuff that we're talking about is not historical.
The fundamental stuff in Hegel is not historical.
So the logic is not about history.
The logic is not about historical categories,
the development of the logic is not historical or temple.
It's eternal outside of time.
But Hegel thinks those eternal metaphysical logical
structures are realized over time
in human history in philosophy.
So what the history of philosophy is,
is the history of philosophers grasping
incompletely mutilated non-systematic parts
of the complete systematic self-development
of non-physical categories.
So once you have Hegel's logic on board,
you can then look back through the history of philosophy
and see aspects of it manifest themselves
in Parmenides, Heraclitus, Plato, Aristotle, et cetera.
Hegel is very dismissive of the medieval
in his lecture of the history of philosophy.
And then there were some medieval.
Let's ignore that.
Let's start up with Descartes, okay?
And really just get to the Germans as quickly as possible.
And so Hegel's, we're gonna end the class
by reading a little bit of Hegel's lectures
on the history of philosophy.
Hegel thinks to confirm this theory,
you have to go back through the history of philosophy
and see this self-developing system
of metaphysical structures, which is called the idea.
You have to see it present in the history of philosophy,
just as you have to see in the history of art,
you have to find in the history of art
the artistic presentation of the idea,
the presentation of the idea in pictures
and sculptures and music, et cetera.
And you have to find in the history of religion
the religious presentation of the idea,
the presentation of the idea in mythology,
in spiritual practice, in holy scriptures, et cetera.
Yeah?
What would be the tell-off of history?
Of what?
Of history?
No, of his system, like the ultimate.
The short answer is-
The historian says the ultimate form,
like the perfect open form.
Reason fully and entirely grasping,
that's all the best reason.
Yeah?
So when history uses phenomenology-
Oh, excellent, yeah, I didn't answer
the original question, yeah, thank you.
So yeah, so the phenomenology in Hegel
is just the science of how science appears,
that is to say, shapes of apparent claims
to knowledge that are not knowledge.
So the science of the experience of consciousness
could also be called the phenomenology of knowledge.
And the phenomenology of spirit is the logos,
the science of how spirit appears to itself
as things that are not yet spirit.
It's spirit in itself but not yet for itself.
It's the scientific exposition of the stages of spirit
in itself but not yet for itself
up to and including spirit in and for itself.
Phenomenology in Husserl is this idea
that what first philosophy should be,
the replacement for metaphysics should be a science
where you just bracket the question
of whether the objects of consciousness
have any being outside of consciousness,
and you study the pure structure of consciousness.
Now, Hegel just thinks, okay, that's cool,
but we've already, we've seen that movie before.
It was called early modern histology.
My general view on, so one of the things
that's frustrating about the Hegel reception
is a lot of people think, oh, you know,
Hegel's a dead dog, let's reject Hegel,
but the objections to Hegel are largely terrible.
And then what's really frustrating
is people think they're gonna do this other thing.
And it's like, okay, that view is already a sub-model
of the phenomenology of spirit.
Like, Hegel is fully aware of that as a possibility.
He foresaw it and he refuted it.
So what are we doing here, guys?
What are we doing here?
Yeah, someone else, yes.
I was gonna say, how would Hegel explain
the kind of experience that, like,
you just go, like, more and more wrong,
for example, like, if I choose the wrong path
of argument in an essay, well, I believe that's true.
And I just go, like, more and more wrong,
like, just the wrong, and.
It's logically independent or orthogonal
to what Hegel is doing in the phenomenology of spirit.
The phenomenology of spirit is not psychology.
This is not a claim of a human psychology
or what human psychology does in respect,
in the face of error.
It's a logical claim about the nature of consciousness.
So you might not care that you're wrong,
but consciousness has such ducts.
And that's why, in general, consciousness,
when it discovers an incoherence
in its own self-conception alters it.
And one way of seeing that,
although this is not the theme of the phenomenology,
is this story is played out in history,
but it's not the topic of the phenomenology.
The key thing is that in absolute knowing
at the end of the book,
Hegel says spirit releases itself into history,
which means that all of this does happen in history,
but it doesn't happen in this order.
And that is not the topic of this book.
So these shapes of consciousness
are historically real.
And historically, when human societies recognize
that their conception of their relationship
to the world is incoherent,
they change, not immediately.
Sometimes they persist in the contradiction.
And then the undoing of that contradiction
can involve massive historical change.
For instance, my country is founded on the idea
that all men are created equal.
It was also founded on economic side
and the exploitation of enslaved people.
That's a contradiction.
You can either think of that contradiction
as having worked out in the Civil War
as we're still not being worked out.
But that's a perfect example of a Hegelian contradiction
worked out historically.
Yeah.
Does consciousness know a symbol
of becoming spirit in its beginning?
No.
Or like, so it only goes to my guess.
It gets some anticipation later on.
Later on, it's like you can see in the distance this thing
and it's like, that would be really awesome.
Early on, consciousness, as we'll see next week
when we talk about the first shape of consciousness,
the first shape of consciousness knows one thing.
This.
What's the grounds of the movement itself?
The grounds of the movement itself is the
the self-reputation of consciousness.
Yeah.
What limits consciousness from knowing the being?
Nothing.
What limits consciousness from knowing the in itself
is all of its conceptions of the in itself and knowing
short of absolute no.
So one way of thinking about the relationship
between Hegel and Kant is Kant thinks
that at least theoretically things themselves
are unavailable to us.
Hegel thinks nothing is unavailable to us.
There might be facts that are unknowable to us,
there might be details of my particular objects,
but there's nothing that is structurally
or logically unknowable to us.
Everything is in principle available
or transparent to spirit.
Consciousness and science of consciousness
both are events?
No, because events happen in time.
None of these, the phenomenology of spirit
is not about any events, it's not about any times.
Hegel illustrates various shapes of consciousness
with historical references.
But people who focus on those things
and take the phenomenology to be about them
in the words of my friend Marcus Gabriel
are expositing Hegel's examples, not Hegel.
They are scholars of Hegel's metaphors,
not of the phenomenology of spirit.
Yeah, in the back.
Yes, last section, paragraph 26.
There's two instances I, well, we were talking about that
in the book, but I'm not going to emphasize
how different from a point of decision between science
or the knowledge, apparent knowledge,
what true knowledge that we declare,
because it's like both and I guess not.
But like in time, science declares-
Just could you just tell me where in some instances?
Yeah, science declares its beam to me its power,
but I'm sure knowing this as much as fuel
to the fact that it is, and it gives out the assurance
that science counts as nothing,
so what does it mean, the science declares its beam
on the standard and-
Oh, so the idea is science says I am science.
So I know stuff.
But the person who doesn't have science,
but thinks they have science, can say the same thing.
They can give the same little speech,
because they both are.
Yes.
This is for the study of study of the last question,
but does Hegel ever provide an explicit justification
of how we can be certain that the conditions
for this whole progression are all identical to success?
How does he know that nature sort of never intervenes
in the progression of consciousness,
and that can all just sort of contain
within consciousness itself?
Okay, so that would be a problem if this were a description
of a concrete process happening in reality.
This is a purely logical or conceptual account.
So the word about nature intervening
or nature not cooperating is no more a problem
than this for a logic textbook.
If you said, how do you know that if P
then Q, then Q, nature might intervene.
Nature might, just at the moment you're concluding
that Q of earth, queen, or meteor might happen.
That's not a problem here.
That might be a problem for Hegel's theory of history.
When you get to Hegel's history,
Hegel's theory of history might have the problem
that well a meteor could come and not wipe out humanity.
I don't think it does have that problem,
but it is standardly read as having that problem.
Yeah.
Just from that hour or on science stuff,
a word is mentioned in the time that I don't understand,
it's the word imitation.
What's that?
Is that something like a reference to your way
of understanding the world?
Imitation is just something that pretends
to be something that it isn't.
So, you know, there's imitation cheese,
which is not cheese.
It's like made out of non-dairy products.
There's imitation crab, which is not crab.
It's all of the most repulsive,
inedible parts of some fish that's been reformed
to make it look like crab and die.
What is intimation?
Oh, intimation, sorry.
Oh, intimation.
Yeah, so an intimation is like when you kind of vaguely
sense that something is gonna happen,
but you can't really say exactly what.
So many of you have an intimation
that this class is gonna become
completely incomprehensible.
That's more than an intimation,
because I've more or less told you that that's gonna happen.
Yeah?
I'll ask you a question.
What is the word natural at to natural?
Good question.
I think what it means,
I think it's supposed to justify
why we start with the shape of consciousness
that we've given.
Namely, it's the most immediate
or least sophisticated possible shape of consciousness.
On the other hand, I mean, sorry,
I didn't ignore that, that's wrong.
What it means by calling that natural consciousness
is that that is the position
of philosophically untrue to common sense.
That's the natural starting point to think about knowledge.
I have a being, there's some other beings,
they're distinct from me.
I've gotta know about them.
How do I do that?
That leads you into the whole problem.
Yeah?
So, sorry, I'm trying to find a way to frame the phone.
So is there a sort of an original point of,
so the being for, the being in itself,
it seems to me it's for Hegel.
It's already at any rate sort of being schematized
already by the consciousness
so that it can make its presence into,
you know, a relationship in knowing.
So, which it's sort of,
a schematization is already a sort of,
a sort of derivation from the original being in itself.
So what you're right about is being in itself here
is the in itself of the object of knowledge,
or the object of consciousness,
which means that the in itself,
insofar as we cannot be conscious of it,
is not on the table.
But remember, the topic here is, what can we know?
So the in itself, insofar as we can't be conscious of it,
is definitely not a topic for epistemology.
Secondly, knowledge here, I just, I keep trying to,
knowledge is extremely general.
It's what, it is the relationship of consciousness
to a topic.
So if we can't be conscious of it,
this in itself that isn't even,
isn't the in itself of the object of consciousness.
If the in itself,
that can't even be an object of consciousness,
how do we even talk about it?
So it's just not relevant.
So the starting point, the original point of,
of dialect is when you take a little movement,
it's already in a mode of knowing, sort of.
Exactly, it's all of this is within a thought.
We're not talking,
the phenomena does not start with beings.
It starts with the relationship of consciousness to beings.
In particular, it starts with the relationship
of consciousness to beings as conceived by consciousness.
Everything is within a thought.
I'll see you next week.
And if you have any questions for today,
please hand them in and they'll just pick.
And if you're auditing, please do not hand in.
Okay.
You need to stop worrying about the nine digits.
Good luck with finishing your application.
Actually, yeah, unless I have a copy.
So are you a Hegelian now?
No, I'm just, I don't know what you're saying.
Is there a Kantian?
Sorry?
I don't even know what he's saying.
Hi.
If you had to describe your position,
last I checked, you were like very into it.
I still am.
I think about him every day.
Okay.
Oh, I mean, theoretically, yeah, like.
So does that cost?
Ancient philosophy.
I can also find a classic department.
So I assume you also have a wonderful,
is there a reason that I was like-
No, he only taught me one class and I wasn't too confident.
But I got a letter from-
I don't understand.
You have to not imagine that it's like
more difficult than it is.
I think my third year-
He's just making some point.
Am I laughing at it?
That's impossible.
I feel like I understand that.
He's telling you what you already know.
Like, you take all the good stuff.
He's like, you gotta be a flop person.
You gotta know stuff.
There's not a lot of flop.
I don't, I don't-
Yeah.
There's no sense to-
No, he's not.
His ontology's too difficult.
He's the easiest person to read.
Literally, you just gotta read sentences after something.
Yeah, but his ontology's so difficult.
He's not.
He's literally just telling someone,
there's just one thing.
There's just one thing.
What do you think about Spinoza?
Spino- I love Spinoza.
We love Spinoza.
Everyone should love Spinoza.
Yeah.
No.
I don't understand.